cette semaine des violences à l'encontre
des juifs et la promotion de la barbarie
navy ont marqué l'actualité provoquant
la conspiration et l'adie nation de tous
ces actes vienne à la suite de
profanations d'édifices catholique 7 ont
été recensés la première semaine de
février
tout se passe comme si à la crise
sociale à la crise territoriale
s'ajoutait une crise encore plus grave
plus grave parce que c'est celle du
coeur qui touche à l'essence même de
notre humanité à l'intimité de chacun de
nous à notre histoire personnelle et
collective
la république parce qu'elle est laïque
se doit de garantir à tous qu'ils
croient ou qu'ils ne croient pas à une
vie et à une des convictions
spirituelles leur est grave
monsieur le premier ministre que
resterait-il d'une société où tout ce
qui relève de la pensée de la
spiritualité ne serait pas garantie
quelles dispositions comptez vous
prendre pour que chaque citoyen puisse
aspirer à une spiritualité apaisées et
que la france reste le pays de la
liberté des lumières et ne deviennent
pas celui de la barbarie et de
l'obscurantisme
ne pensez vous pas que le moment est
venu de nommer les fauteurs de trouble
jeu vont pour vous répondre
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre le premier
mini jupe et la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur vous
m'interrogez sur la multiplication des
actes antisémites sur la multiplication
des actes de profanation d'un certain
nombre de lieux de culte catholiques ou
juifs sur le climat à nauséabond qui se
développe dans notre pays
vous me posez cette question avec
beaucoup de gravité en indiquant votre
indignation et en indiquant que vous ne
pouvez pas vous contenter de cette
indignation et que vous souhaitez qu'en
réponse à ces actes des politiques
publiques des réactions effective puisse
avoir lieu je voudrais monsieur le
sénateur vous assurer que nous sommes de
ce point de vue parfaitement en ligne
car oui depuis quelques semaines oh
malheureusement ces actes ne date pas
d'il ya quelques semaines ils ne se sont
jamais complètement arrêtée dans notre
pays mais enfin depuis quelques semaines
nous constatons une multiplication de
ces actes d actes antisémites
inacceptable répugnant qui prennent des
formes extrêmement variés des menaces
contre les personnes des tags des
attaques contre les symboles vous avez
vu comme moi je sais que nous aurons
l'occasion au cours de cette séance de
question d'évoquer ce sujet la teinte
faite à la mémoire d'ilan halimi à
sainte geneviève des bois
face à cette multiplication d'actes
antisémites ou anti catholique
s'agissant des églises et des cimetières
vous faites bien monsieur le sénateur de
rappeler que la république respecte le
sacré car en france dans notre
république nous avons le droit de croire
ou de ne pas croire
et lorsque nous croyons nous devons être
respectée parce que nous croyons
toujours en france est toujours sous la
république
on a respecté les églises les cimetières
les lieux de culte et il est impératif
de rappeler qu'il doit toujours en être
ainsi
ça ne suffit pas de le dire j'en ai
parfaitement conscience monsieur le
sénateur mais vous savez comme moi que
le jour où nous ne le dirons plus alors
tout serait perdu nous devons donc
rappelé la norme la norme c'est qu'en
france on respecte les lieux sacrés
symboles de la république
les lieux de culte les lieux où reposent
les morts nous leur devons le respect
c'est un impératif qui s'impose à tous
et qu'il convient systématiquement de
rappeler mais ça ne suffit pas vous avez
raison il faut aller plus loin c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons avec le
gouvernement mais au fond ces sujets
s'inscrivent dans une ligne d'action
dans un continuum d'action nous avons
souhaité agir sur plusieurs domaines en
matière en matière d'abord de formation
car aussi scandaleux ces actes
antisémites ou anti culturelle sur dire
puisse style nous paraître
nous devons faire en sorte qu'ils soient
mieux déceler qu'il soit mieux
retranscrit par les forces de l'ordre
qu'ils puissent être faire l'objet
d'instructions plus complète par les
services de la justice et de sanctions
plus sévères à bon sens par la
magistrature ses efforts de formation
nous avons engagé chez les forces de
police et les forces de gendarmerie
auprès des magistrats ils sont
indispensables
les efforts d'éducation aussi et c'est
un combat anciens c'est un combat
permanent est un combat difficile qu'il
faut livrer contre l'obscurantisme
contre l'ignorance et parfois contre
c'est peu de dire l'obscurantisme c'est
presque encore encore bienveillant nous
devons livrer ce combat à l'école
partout et nous savons qu'il est
difficile je me souviens monsieur le
président que l'expression hussard noir
désigné autant la couleur qui revêtait
les instituteurs que la logique de
combat qui les inspire est le combat
contre l'obscurantisme il faut que nous
retrouvions d'une certaine façon cette
logique est que nous livrions absolument
partout et en tout lieu
ce combat contre l'obscurantisme contre
la haine contre les préjugés contre la
bêtise la plus crasse contre la
méchanceté la plus vive éducation
formation dénonciation et sanctions
c'est indispensable sanction sévère car
les faits sont inacceptables
transformation de notre droit nous
aurons l'occasion au cours de l'année
2019 de soumettre et d'étudier avec
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat des
dispositions législatives qui
permettront de faire évoluer le droit
notamment la responsabilité de ceux qui
gèrent les réseaux sociaux afin qu' il
ne puisse se contenter de dire nous ne
sommes pas des éditeurs
nous sommes au fond des hébergeurs ne
sommes pas responsables de ce qui se dit
sur nos réseaux c'est inacceptable
nous ne pouvons pas l'accepter il nous
faut donc changer le droit à changer le
droit communautaire
nous avons engagé cette discussion avec
nos partenaires et sans attendre changer
le droit national c'est ce que nous
ferons au cours de l'année 2019
et puis nous devons nommer tous ceux qui
commettent ces actes
tous ceux qui collectent ces actes
antisémites avec les vieilles racines de
l'antisémitisme français et les
nouvelles avec ce cet antisémitisme qui
n'a jamais été je le dis car ce serait
trop simple l'apanage d'une famille
politique mais qui s'est déployée dans
de très nombreux dans de très nombreuses
familles politiques dans de très
nombreux aspects de la société française
parfois très vivement parfois très
discrètement l'antisémitisme aussi
résurgent et qui se développe liés aux
amalgames du conflit israélo-palestinien
au développement d'un radics d'une
radicalisation d'un radicalisme
islamistes tous ces éléments toutes ses
constituantes de l'antisémitisme qui se
développe dans notre pays doivent être
combattus doivent être nommés avec une
indéfectible détermination je voudrais
assurer le sénat que je suis attaché à
cette cause de l'indéfectible
détermination de l'ensemble des membres
du gouvernement sur ce sujet merci
monsieur le premier ministre de l'ej&e
de lège
merci monsieur le premier ministre de
cette réponse je crois et vous l'avez
souligné qu'il faut avoir le courage de
nommer les auteurs les auteurs on les
connaît c'est l'extrême gauche anti
sioniste c'est l'islam radical qui va
imposer la charia et celle na vi
c'est l'extrême droite qui regrette
cette période de la france alors
permettez-moi de vous inviter très
respectueusement à méditer cette belle
phrase d'albert camus
mal nommer les choses c'est ajouter du
malheur au monde